[Applause]
[Music]
I want to make some biological
assumptions so short men build muscle
faster and so you're not that short but
you're on the short
side
tall I know I'm a GI okay on a good day
okay I'll round up to 57
kale about you um 6ot flat like on a
good day on a great day no that makes
sense cuz I'm also like
6 they're so cool yeah I just slouch a
lot so to make the other show people
feel better at first I thought it was
going to be a full like I was the odd
man out and everyone else was a bunch of
jacked bodybuilders but instead I was
happy to see that it was just more
people who kind of look like me like
they you know work out occasionally but
they're still like regular people when I
saw Ally I was say okay she's a sleeper
like sleeper buil girl I can tell she's
strong and then I saw Chad I was like
he's I don't know ambiguous I was like
he could be strong could be weak I don't
know I'll be realistic I feel I don't
know if I'm the strongest cuz I'm Caleb
I'm a little nervous I feel like
stronger I want to say I'm at least a
little in the middle or maybe a little
up higher but somewhere in between I
don't feel weakest would best describe
Big Friendly Giant right here yeah I
don't think so either did anyone hear
trainers I'm a trainer all right trainer
cool not a trainer okay so yeah so let's
let's use her logic first so you're the
strongest right now and
then I was like who are you talking to I
I really feel like you're definitely
stronger than most of us so if we're
okay I'm finally shifting him this way
you right here yeah right here that I'd
like to put myself right just maybe in
front of Caleb if that's everyone's okay
with that NP no no I feel like yeah yeah
all I can already tell you that we're
definitely underestimating you too
there's no way you guys are like I
actually think you're probably
like those
legs some I see the dark board that's
certified gym Weare know she's wearing
Converse Converse like a lifting Sho I
love I'm just going to say upper body is
my upper body girl okay I let's just the
way you look could tell you you're you
Aquaman man you come over here Aquaman
you DC like I think I look a lot scarier
than I actually am so I would be
probably like swapping yeah go ahead
nice to meet you great great do any of
our gals feel like they should be
ranking higher than any of our guys I
feel like she needs I feel like I feel
like I could take you off yeah I'm like
not that
way yeah you need to feel like she just
CrossFit like she's strong arm wrestle
and deadlift like or like hanging yes
everything else I don't I feel like we
might be even let everybody elde I think
she's stronger than me and I think she's
stronger than like some of y'all for
sure I do think that like just in the
lifting Community um a lot of guys
underestimate girls and it's just like
something I experienced ever since like
I started working out because in the
beginning like so many guys would come
up to me and try to tell me how to do my
workout need help no I don't need help
actually you guys ready yeah here's your
initial ranking oh okay all right all
right here we
[Music]
go go for it and then you're ready all
right all
right I'm so excited she already got it
you're going to do better than me let's
go let's go
nothing
sorry
[Applause]
go I'm sorry I'm sorry Let It Go Again
oh I I'll try 315 yeah yeah
okay about to throw all all right good
good good
good well should I start with my Max or
should I just you know you have three so
why don't you start with something like
right below it um do like 275 then okay
okay go for it all right
India go okay okay
e easy too easy a plate dude all right
all right all right all right all
right that was it that was it that was
it that was good good oh my gosh okay
I'm good I'm
nervous I'm scared you're hell where's
my mommy you ready you got it you got
it oh easy that was easy that was good
all right let's do like
260 all right let's go up up up up easy
all right nice okay now you guys you did
three
plates you got
[Applause]
it no really close how was good that was
so good all right that good that was a
really good attempt I think all right
Chad come up to the bar there you go all
right come a little bit closer you want
don't be afraid of it now
yeah right come on grab the
bar squat y yellow here you can okay
okay Prett good that was a great that
was a great yeah that was bad at all I
feel light I feel I feel better try to
keep the bar oh oh my okay the way his
back oh my God please be careful I feel
better wait a second please you're back
please
I'm Chad and this is not what I
[Laughter]
do okay you got it you got it you got
it the double jointedness that's what
that's that's what helps me out all
right do you want us to
yell I did my bad right all right right
right all
right too easy too easy numb let's go
but I'm I'm going to I'm going to be
careful though you can do it you got it
this is easy all right this easy light
weight right not for me but for you you
got it dude you got it you got it yeah
come on come
on nice could have done more than that
slip it off my hands a little
bit let's
go
DMX all right right here we go all right
you got it bro come on easy this is easy
for you this is easy wa all right
oh right all right good that hurt my
soul bro all right uh let's add a 25 to
it
[Applause]
go dude that was sick all right okay all
right he can do
[Applause]
it got
what would you like we add a 25 add a 2
25 to this I told you guys I literally
455 all right
455 dang it's time for a pep talk all
right so you're going to beat you're
going to beat us go all right we'll buy
you lunch lch lunch I'm down yeah that's
like that's that's that's light work
yes nice
[Applause]
job go get him
easy my gosh he he it dude the
bar that was insane like crazy I could
go up a little bit
more you want to do some more waiting
looks weird looks like like an alien man
man come
on go dang
bro here we here we go here we go let's
go baby let's go go you got it you got
it you got it the bar come on come on
just stand up come on
[Applause]
come look at
that easy okay okay who did the math I
like to credit that from to my you
know
deadlift is my strongest lift I I don't
miss any days I eat I I get sleep like
sleep is so important people really
underestimate
[Music]
that on the left we have Chad who lifted
.92 of your body weight then we have
Melissa lifted 1.04 of your body weight
then we have Caleb who lifted 1.65 of
your body weight go ahead
right
now then we have India who lifted
2.17 your body weight then we have
Nathan who lifted
2.31 times your body weight and then we
have Allison who lifted
2.7 times your body weight then we have
Johnny who lifted
3.21 times your body weight
[Applause]
I'm a bad example women are typically
smaller than men right and so like our
numbers may not seem as like impressive
so that's why something like body weight
makes a lot more sense cuz like you know
Allison like just lifted crazy him out
um and she's like 100 something3 lb
almost three times your body exctly so I
I like I like this kind of measurement
this is nice we're like the two who
actually compete in power liting and so
um I don't know it wasn't that
surprising to me because like this is
what we do every day it makes me kind of
happy cuz it's like I put in the work
for it because uh I started powerlifting
because I don't I didn't like feeling
helpless and like that's kind of like
how you feel sometimes when you're like
a girl and people underestimate you I'm
really happy with how how much I've
grown because I was really really
underweight I'm glad like I've gotten to
a healthier place in general I don't
think I would ever go back
Allison she caught me off guard for sure
yeah she lifting 300 at her weight class
is pretty impressive it's really
impressive actually I was a little too
cocky going into it I'm like okay
they're not bodybuilders they're more my
size I can you know nah so I'd say it
was a fair ranking and then just kind of
gives me more motivation to just you
know keep going more to the gym and just
kind of bulk up more you guys are
noticing but as I'm looking down to you
have like like powerlifter powerlifter
man woman trainer trainer man woman
likes Athletics but we're not quite
there man woman and
Chad just just hip hop extraordinaire
I'm Chad and I'm
here